gros chapitre sportif maintenant avec
tout d'abord bien évidemment la superbe
finale de roland garros en beauté
rapporté au terme de près de cinq heures
de jeu par le jeune suédois villans
d'air qui n'a pas 18 ans aux dépens d'un
des hommes les plus en forme du moment
guillermo vilas l'argentin un début de
saison exceptionnel 25 matchs en grands
prix sans défaite il a l'expérience il
est favori à droite on petit wilander le
jeune se doit de 17 ans et demi la
révélation de roland garros 82 moralité
de l'histoire le petit à manger le gros
aujourd'hui sur la terre battue de
roland garros début de match difficile
pour wilander pourtant il avait éliminé
au tour précédent lendl giroul haïti
c'est clair il a du mal à entrer dans le
match aujourd'hui
il perd le premier set 6-1 les balles
liftées de villas sont profonds lourdes
elles gênent considérablement wilander
il ne trouve pas la distance et puis au
2e set cela va mieux avec son revers à
deux mains wilander trouve de meilleurs
angles l'attaquent même de temps en
temps les villages je voyais fait mieux
que résister avec ce passing shot
croisés mais vilas commence déjà à
douter l'argentin perd le deuxième le
troisième set et au quatrième set
wilander obtient trois balles de match
la deuxième sera la bonne trop de fautes
du côté de villa ce une tactique
incertaine une résistance qui s'est
émoussée devant l'extraordinaire
envoyeur qu'est le jeune suédois au bout
de 4 heures 45
victoire sans équivoque
mats wilander en finale des
internationaux de france et pardon maths
je sais que vous n'aimez pas ça mais
comment ne pas vous comparez à björn
borg
il ya huit ans comme vous il foulait le
tapis rouge et gagner roland garros pour
la première fois pour lui succéder au
palmarès des internationaux de france
je vous souhaite comme un big book
éditions